who like cat podcast special guests in
here
flipping NJ AKA whoa your your aka's
flipping NJ but yeah this is this is
Caesar Pena man welcome to the show oh
thank you thank you thanks for having me
first of all congratulations you and
Andy uh have built I want to say like a
like an Empire man yeah you know
obviously you've been doing the real
estate thing a lot longer but you guys
kind of came together you have the
seminars just booming and recent news if
you guys starting uh your own TV show
the 50 Cent backed at a e right yep so
congrats man thank you man yeah what is
the uh for what you guys do obviously
um what is the angle of the TV show
our TV show is going to be different
than every other any other real estate
show you've seen on TV just uh when you
look at most of the shows the flipping
shows very cookie cutter they don't
really show you like uh the development
side of real estate they don't show you
rental the rental property inside of
real estate they're going to show you
dealing with tenants you know all that
stuff yeah so we're kind of gonna focus
on everything we're still going to show
flips right we're still going to show
you know we also Mentor a lot of
celebrities too and uh and regular
people we're gonna show that side of it
and you know pretty much all around
everything in real estate you could
imagine that you've never seen before on
TV yeah because like that's like kind of
the the part that we don't see is like
dealing with a crazy tenant or just like
some of the I mean I've seen some of the
properties that you've flipped in like
man
I hear that you like well you've said
this before that you'll just buy
properties off of auction.com without
seeing them in person right yeah so
pretty much man sometimes to me it's
just numbers right so the numbers make
sense in New Jersey the numbers make
sense in Chicago it's just numbers so I
buy properties all the time Hub uh from
hubzu auction.com
um just off the picks just off of picks
and just the numbers yeah that's crazy
uh talk about like um one how did you
for people who don't know I mean you've
sold the story a lot but just what's
like a quick synopsis on how you got
like your past and how you got uh
initially started in um into the real
estate game so my story is not a
traditional real estate story right a
real estate investor story so
uh I barely have a high school diploma
yeah right uh my parents I don't come
for money nobody in my family owned any
real estate so when I graduated high
school instead of going to college like
my friends did I chose the streets right
so everybody told me if you don't change
your life you're gonna end up in prison
and then a lesson I ended up in prison
so but at that point I turned a negative
into a positive so when I was in prison
there was a guy uh his name is Renee
which he's to this day he's my big
brother yeah he was a big real estate
developer in Hoboken New Jersey yep he
was one of the first guys that invested
in Hoboken when Hoboken was Urban
and then you know of course whole Balkan
is probably one of the most expensive
places in New Jersey yeah so he went in
uh he had a charge for political
corruption he's never been in prison
before I taught him how to bid and he
taught me about real estate when you say
bid what is it that's all about you know
to kind of tell him how everything
worked in prison right just kind of the
politics yeah the politics the right
thing to do you know don't cut nobody on
the phone don't don't cut nobody on the
the child line right you know uh don't
sit here don't say you know stuff like
that watch TV in this TV you were like
his big homie in jails yeah yeah yeah
even though like
yeah yeah so
um what was your first like do you
remember your first property was it a
successful one so when I get out of jail
which is crazy this was the wild cowboy
days back in
2006 right so it's right but this before
the crash happened so right which is
people always ask me that I can't
believe this so right out the half uh
out of prison I go to the halfway house
and I started doing mortgages wow so
here I am in the halfway house and I
have access to people's information that
just came out of prison right but those
were the wild cowboy days right yeah so
I I come home I started doing mortgages
you know it was crazy back then in that
market I remember my first loan that I
did the lady was 80 years old she bought
a house for 480 000 and we got her 100
financing
what the [ __ ] if she was actually great
wait like I said crazy everybody was
getting approved for houses but back
then if you bought a house right I will
buy a house because you bought a house
to compete with you and I would get
approved like the next day there's no
problem yeah you buy a house today and
it's worth fifty thousand dollars more
the next day you could you go and cash
out and get a lot of credit that's crazy
it was crazy back there right that's why
the bubble happened so I came home
started doing mortgages was doing great
you know straight out of prison I'm
making 15 20 000 a month right which is
awesome then Market collapses
my wife's Cube and I'm Dominican so we
opened up a Cuban restaurant we had no
business opening up a restaurant right
we don't know nothing about the
restaurant tough business tough business
my mother-in-law uh she's a chef so we
opened up the restaurant and you know we
were kind of counting our heart right
right so
first two months we're doing great right
the next thing you know man we just it
was we got into the restaurant business
that's when there was like a shortage
right of everything I think it was like
e for shortage or something like that so
rights went up flower went up everything
everything went up right a back a box of
plantings went from like 20 to like
ninety dollars right Jesus so
we're in the restaurant for like a year
and a half we lost everything we I came
home doing great with mortgages switched
to this right losing everything again we
had uh two houses and foreclosures that
we owned at the time and
um I saw an opportunity in real estate I
took it
and I made 70 000 and we closed the
restaurant the next day what were the
details on the that first seventy
thousand that was a three family home in
Paterson New Jersey okay yeah and I I
did that as a flip so you bought it
fixed it up flipped it yep so I I
actually bought it uh and the market was
still at that point not going down all
the way so it was still like right there
so I bought it and I sold it to somebody
else and made a quick seventy thousand
wow yep that's crazy how did you did you
what was your financing process for that
first house well uh the person that
bought it off for me they bought a cash
and I got it I got that house if I
remember correctly uh I believe it was
FHA wow yeah yeah
um so that that's one thing I think that
you explained pretty well is I think a
lot of people
they don't understand all of the options
that they have
to acquire rental properties to acquire
properties to invest in I think uh we're
in a really weird space right now
because the rates went up yeah and I
don't feel like the property value has
adjusted to the rate hike yet no
um would you suggest people buying right
now because it feels like it's kind of
like at least just I'm not an expert
like you but it for my from my
perspective it feels like it's probably
the wrong time to buy
so right now the Market's a little funny
right
it is
anybody buying a single family home I
will kind of hold off on that because
that's where you're going to see your
biggest correction yeah right as far as
rental properties multi-families it's on
fire
like it's not gonna stop because rents
are up so high right right so you know
I'll give you an example like uh three
family Paterson New Jersey you probably
get it right now for 500 000 right but
just you know just simple numbers right
let's name account taxes say uh you get
a seven percent right
oh maybe you buy the rate down and get a
six percent let's say it's three
thousand what's the rate right now
as of yesterday uh it was like 6.9 for
30-year fix uh
for a 15 year it was like 6.5 damn it's
crazy how much it jumped and then the
adjustable was a little bit lower right
yeah so let's say right now you go to
Patterson and let's say you get lucky
you buy the rate down you get a property
for 500 000. you buy that property uh
let's say your mortgage just round
numbers right now getting to all of it
right let's say it's three thousand
dollars a month right
so right lower right
in that market right in your apartment
you go to the three family you could get
about 4 500 a month right
so
you actually make more money now the
rate is actually higher
Sprints are so high so now instead of
getting fifteen hundred dollars for that
apartment I'm getting 2 500.
um so I'm not making 7 500 compared to
making the 45 right yeah my mortgage is
let's say three thousand plus taxes
Insurance whatever that is it I'm at 5
000 let's say Olin I'm still making 2500
a month yeah so that's the difference
yeah and like and and you're in a place
where you know you have tenants so it's
like
if it ever corrects you can refinance
right
if the rate goes down you know
straight right no more rates have always
been between five to six yeah what's
what happened recently was kind of like
fake because they were trying to save
the housing market from covid right yeah
so it's like we got kind of spoiled for
sure my first property that I bought it
was when I stayed alone back in 04 and
my interest rate was eight percent wow
the only difference was that back then
right compared to now
the uh the rates were high but the rents
didn't support the mortgage payment yeah
now the rents even if you want a single
family support whatever the payment is
monthly because the rents are so high
yep so you can still cash flow in any
Market at the rental side so let's say
somebody has let's say they've saved up
50 bands right they got 50k and they
want to they're making decent money
let's say they're making I don't know
150 000 a year 100 say they're in the
six figures with the low six figures
range and they want to get into getting
their first rental property
um I know there's like tons of options
for people to
um whether it's a hard money loan
obviously there's a conventional loan
you mentioned the FHA loan earlier if
you're that person what route are you
taking to try to uh to to get get that
first property right in today's climate
right now if you have no experience
right I wouldn't do a flip and I
wouldn't do a property to rehab I would
definitely get a rental as cash flowy
right uh that that's what I would do
right it all depends what program you
want to use right right you could do FHA
display and put a three and a half
percent down you could uh do a
conventional product I think uh
conventional right now on a two family
investment you get away with putting ten
percent down
uh you could go state it right the
stated program that kind of caused the
bubble last time it's back what is the
stated thing so stay the program now
it's called well it's it's really it's
not called stated anymore it's the asset
based load right so meaning you don't
have to show any tax returns you put uh
15 to 20 percent
rental income to the property is making
so they're they'll pretty much completed
one in which they know that you're
renting the property out because they
have to be able to see the numbers make
sense yeah so the numbers that the
numbers have to make sense all you need
is good credit right you need probably
at least uh 680 credit score you need uh
to show the the money in the bank it
doesn't have to be seasoned or the money
you could just transfer right over it's
not like a FHA product but they're not
going to be like it'll show us two years
of your bank statements yes it's not
like that
um you need an appraisal title
the leases for the property that's it
you get a loan in 45 to 60 days wow
which that program is very popular right
now because a lot of people don't don't
aren't qualifying for conventional
Finance right so that that program
everybody's using it right now wow and
then for like a hard money loan or a
line of credit situation would you say
that those are more the options you
would go to if you need to make a like a
flip on a property yeah because it's
more of a short-term thing right
definitely you know as far as flipping
properties hard money is the way to go
yeah right uh hard money right now what
experience you're looking at uh 90 90 on
to Value 100 on the rehab meaning you
only got to put 10 down and they're
going to give you all the rehab dollars
for people who don't know what a hard
money loan is just kind of break it down
so Harmony loan is pretty much private
financing yeah it's a way of moving
quicker because when it comes to
rehabbing properties uh there is not a
lot of options it's either a hard money
loan or a FHA 203k loan FHA free k loan
you have to live in the property okay
our money is what is pretty much for
investors yeah right it goes under an
LLC it doesn't appear on your personal
credit report right but you have to it
costs money right yeah the interest
rate's a lot higher it's a lot higher it
could be anywhere between eight to
twelve percent but you move fast right
and real estate when you find a good
deal that's the whole thing you need
speed you need to have that cash rate
that's it so hard money is considered
the same thing as cash so when you go on
the auction side and it tells you cash
only technically that means that you can
also use hard money
um it means the same thing where do you
like because I know that like there's
different types of hard money lenders
but like for people who have no idea how
to find a hard money lender or how to
even get
involved in that world like where did
where is a good place to start with that
well when I first started it was a
little bit harder right because I got
back in a way when everything crashed
but now there's hard money lenders
everywhere yeah yeah there's Harmony
levels everywhere you know you could
type in a hard money lender and uh just
on Google on Instagram anywhere and it
pops up and like those what they do is
essentially they have a like they do
their insurance is the property right
yeah so pretty much a Harmony lender
will not do a deal unless there's me on
the bone it has to make sense right so
for example if you're trying to flip a
property right and it needs to rehab and
it's worth 300 000 right and you're
paying 300 000 they're not gonna do that
deal because God forbid if you don't pay
and they take the property away there's
no meat on the boat yeah there's no
problem they're gonna break even what's
the point of them risking it now if that
property if it's worth 300 000 but you
get it for 220. and you're all in yeah
what rehab
yeah so pretty much a government rule
that kind of gives you an idea
30 money to make for foreign
that's another day
they don't want you to pay because they
want your deal right so yeah you pay the
higher interest rate whatever but at the
end of the day it's all about risk so
they want to make sure this deal is
worth it and got it another deal
yo there is like an art I got a homie uh
DJ Christian in the Tampa area who uh
he's been flipping houses for 10 years
now and
he always would tell me there's like
little things when you flip a house like
you could go go down to the color of the
door like what are some of the like
random little like things that people
don't think about let's say if they're
rehabbing a house to flip or if they're
just rehabbing a house to add some value
to their own property like what are some
of those like hacks that that you always
make sure your houses have
well when it comes to different
properties right and rental properties
yeah
I only go into the properties when I do
my walkthrough to make sure the uh you
know it's worth it before my contractors
go in there right and kind of tell them
but we already have a system in place
where
I don't have to be there or even talk to
my guys anymore they pretty much know
everything that you have to do because
the problem is with these properties
right at the end of the day you want to
make money yeah my first property that I
purchased to flip this was a flip
property I went in there I wanted
everything designer to paint this I went
crazy with it I want to do this I want
to do that the nicest thing everything
nice yeah it was a three it was a three
family that was flipping at the time
and two of the units I had tenants in
them so me and my wife are arguing about
fixtures right that right nightmare
and then I go back to the property I
ended up having to evict somebody right
in that unit and in six months
right and I'm like yo all this headache
picking all these nights
now with me it's just a system right I
buy everything in bulk for my Apartments
the same floors everything and it's just
automatic think about it my guys don't
gotta think about it that's hey what up
yo bootleg Kev gotta stop the interview
to tell you about our newest sponsor man
shout out to the homies at hardean Las
Vegas that's right the number one
dispensary in the whole state of Nevada
let alone in the whole [ __ ] country
so many choices of Premium cannabis
ladies and gentlemen it is like how can
I put this you walk into it you go to
hardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg Capt sent me they're
gonna take care of you at hardean when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
hardeen is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview so once
you identify that system it makes
everything so much easier yep because
you're because it's like you're scaling
just yo we know what our yeah
yeah because I mean right now there's
obviously a shortage on a lot of
supplies and stuff has that made things
like a little more difficult for you or
is it just you just got to pay more yeah
you know for me on the rental side of
the business it doesn't affect me right
because yeah I'm paying more for
material but I'm making more on the
right on the rent yeah right and before
even you know wood all the other stuff
you know uh wire whatever it was
it didn't really matter because the
values went up so high after covet right
so you were still making that money up
anyway right right right that was a
little different but again the market
right now the values have not got down
yet right it's probably not going to
happen for another you're probably
looking at like about a year yeah about
another year right before you really see
a big change right especially in the
tri-state area where we are like values
are just like yeah like we're still
getting five ten offers on the property
crazy yeah so it hasn't changed yet
maybe eventually it will but again you
don't know what could happen a year from
now I was gonna say would you if
somebody was watching this who is a
first-time investor or they not not
trying to purchase a a property for
themselves to live in but let's say they
want to do a flip you said first of all
you said you advise people not to do a
flip off the back right yeah
but would you advise people to wait for
the adjustment to happen or since rental
prices are so high it's okay to take the
risk on the uh full price of the home
possibly dipping in a year year and a
half but the rent's so high that it
doesn't matter yeah I would definitely
throw a rental property right
when the market changes
right if it changes a year from now well
you're really gonna get hurt or see a
difference is let's say you're a first
time flipper you come into the market
you buy this property now right and uh
eight months from now the value drops
yeah and then it took you so long to get
that property on the market you can get
hurt yeah because you're new to flipping
a house exactly things don't happen as
quick as if you were to flip a house
because people don't have their system
in place
five six months by then I mean imagine
if you bought a house in February and it
by June your house was over yeah it's
changed the demands change for buying a
single family home you know because you
got on the stand right there right now
right we're in October right so any sale
that closes right now any High sale you
can use that comp for a whole year right
when it comes to uh anything from uh
from a condo all the way to a four
family right so that comp is good for
for the next year so account from that
they sold for 550 is still good next
year right for 12 months most appraisers
though they'll come out they're like
maybe they like they value six months
but that comp is good yeah so now when
you don't have comps anymore right
that's when the market changes because
now you don't have high comps anymore
now you got to go on the new value so if
you're a newbie flipper or anybody got
into the flipping game that you can't
get the property done within the next
six months you could get hurt right so
if somebody let's say they have a couple
of rental properties and they want to do
a flip they found a good deal right what
are some of those things that you you
have your system in place what are the
things that you can save money on
whether it's fixtures whether it's
lighting whether it's tile and one of
the things that you're like don't cut
corners on these things this is
important these things you can find
deals on like
you know at the end of the day right
it's not really
it's old numbers right
and you have to learn your numbers
because that's how you get ripped off
especially by contractors right right
the thing says it all con tractors right
so I always buy my own material because
when you deal with a contractor they
usually uh put something on top raise
the price you know between 10 to 20
percent right
um you never want to give a contractor
too much money right that's a big
mistake that I learned at the beginning
you always want to break down that
payment at least anywhere between four
to six right payments because when you
give a contract too much money at a
certain point he gets lazy yeah because
he already has most of your money now he
has most of your money now he moves on
to the next job another guy is going to
give him more money wait wait you owe
him that happens all the time yeah so
you gotta you know you got to watch
things like that yeah buy a bulk
whenever I see a good sale I buy a bulk
just anything yeah anything yeah what is
it what is something that you've noticed
has gone up the most right now like just
as it obviously Woods I mean we always
hear about wood is it well what what
actually went down so what's not bad
steel is up like crazy yeah so uh
besides the flips right the regular
rentals we also develop properties from
scratch so right now I'm putting up a 50
unit building in Paterson New Jersey 80
unit and 100 unit right Jesus I just
finished my foundation and uh I just got
a quote for steel and it's almost up 50
cents more
then when I got a quote for it about six
months ago wow yeah so it's it's pretty
big so as of today man because you uh
okay so that first house you flipped and
made 70k on what year was that
that was back in uh 2000
8 2007 or another so fast forward to now
how many doors do you have currently as
far as doors and doors there we also
have other construction Nationwide we're
probably at about 2 800. wow 2800 and I
probably have right now about 800 other
units on the contract wow
um you know most of my portfolio is in
New Jersey about 70 but I also have been
expanding to the Midwest yeah you're
telling me yeah so I've been buying a
lot in Chicago Chicago is a great Market
to invest in uh I kind of see what I did
in Patterson in Chicago right and then
these old numbers when I first started
in Paterson New Jersey our average rent
was 900 right Rent Now is 2500 to 3 000.
wow in Chicago the average rent when I
first got there about a year and a half
ago was about a thousand to Eleven
Hundred they're already up to fourteen
hundred right this is going up when I
look at units right especially on the
commercial side I look at the price per
unit what I could buy it from when I
started in Paterson I was buying per
unit twenty thousand dollars a unit
right so 10 uh 10 unit 20 000 a unit 200
000 right
so now
I'm in the Midwest and I'm paying well
well to backtrack a little bit so now
those units that I bought in New Jersey
now I'm selling them for 150 to 200 000
per unit wow in a matter of five to ten
years
in Chicago I'm paying uh ten thousand to
thirty thousand a unit in less than two
years is already up to 70 to 80 000 a
unit wow so I kind of see what I did
here I'm doing over there it's like it's
like kind of getting up to that level
now let me ask you this man because
obviously
you talked earlier about dealing with
bike
crazy tenants uh that seems to be the
biggest headache perceptually when we
think of like
um
being a landlord right obviously
especially during covet there was a lot
of uh
Like rules that protect the tenants and
not pay rent and I know a lot of people
took advantage of that oh yeah
um talk about that side of it man
because it's obviously the side that's
not as glamorous and that seems to be
one of the sides of this thing that can
can be the most stressful I mean
you notice when it comes to dealing with
tenants most people don't know this part
that you look at a property manager
right you can pay a property manager
five to ten percent you don't deal with
they're going to headaches they handle
everything they handle everything yeah
nobody's gonna call you they don't have
no heat they're not going to call you
that the toilet is running you just hire
a property management company that's it
yeah they they kind of yeah they could
be anywhere between five to ten percent
that they charge right yeah but it's
worth it yeah so think about it right
like let's say you got a unit that
you're getting a thousand dollars a
month and 100 five ten percent fifty two
hundred dollars yeah you don't deal with
it you don't deal with a headache yeah
the one thing though when it comes to
rental properties right when you want to
be a landlord you have to be intended in
landlord-friendly States right you don't
want to be in a talent-friendly state so
New Jersey is landlord friendly right
Atlanta Florida Chicago their Orlando
friendly States meaning in Florida you
can pick somebody in about two to three
weeks the show goes in the house and
throws all your stuff out like it's
crazy over there right Atlanta is pretty
quickly uh Chicago New York is anywhere
between I mean Chicago and New Jersey
I'm sorry it's very it's very 45 days
it's still lagging it's getting back to
normal now so it's probably about 60 to
70 days right
uh California
you're [ __ ] in California just like uh
New York yeah uh New York right now
people probably gonna wait Coleman and
everything else before covert it took
you about a year to fix somebody in New
York wow that was probably up to like
two years
so people could just sit on it and you
got to eat that mortgage and then take
advantage oh my God
and that that that's just one of the the
things you got to be careful what state
when it comes to uh that you want to be
a landlord because of stuff like that
where you like not get into certain
markets oh 100 yeah 100 yeah that's wild
man
have you uh look when you have 2 800
doors and you have so much stuff
happening
um
how I mean how do you keep up with the
financials like how do you keep up with
everything do you have an accountant
does your wife help like what is this oh
yeah my wife is eating on my right hand
I was gonna say because like one of the
biggest things is like I feel like when
you start making that much money
um people make mistakes man Things fall
through the crack they don't dot their
eyes they don't cross their T's so what
are the things that like you would just
suggest people make sure they have in
line if you once you've kind of start
getting that many streams of income
coming in you definitely want to have a
good real estate accountant right when I
first started I was using uh this
accountant right she was local I used
her for a couple years
and one day she tells me caesar I'm
learning with you
and I'm like what do you mean you're
learning with me
as you're doing real estate I'm learning
with you so but I'm like you're the
professional you're supposed to be
teaching me that tricks of the time so
at that point I knew I had to change the
concerts right and now I have a a new
accountant uh you know that I save a lot
of money with right because real estate
is one of those uh Financial Vehicles
where you don't pay a lot when it comes
to taxes right there's so many loopholes
in the tax code right that are actually
legal right uh so you definitely need a
good real estate accountant to take
advantage of those loopholes you got to
put a good team together when it comes
to property managers right and
contractors uh contractor part whenever
I find a contractor is really good I
just keep them year round
like I just hired him to keep him in the
house you'll be like yo you work for me
yeah and then of course you need uh good
property management software like we use
AppFolio I thought it was really good
um talk about uh just the process of
finding homes for people who don't know
like um
and you've always talked about
auction.com but
what what would what would you uh like I
said Somebody's just knew they got some
money in the bank they got decent credit
they want to get this thing popping
where would they go first well right now
it's just building relationships right
because the auction sites ever since
Kobe hit they haven't had a lot of
inventory right but now it's getting
flooded again little by little more
properties are coming to the market so
people that have more opportunity uh I
do the auction sites uh the county the
county sheriff sales right or state
service sales it all depends right I go
to those you could pick up deals there
uh another good relationship is to have
a a good relationship a build a good
relationship with an estate attorney a
lot of times when people pass away uh
the errors usually don't want to deal
with the properties with the buildings
or whatever it is I've picked up a lot
of deals like that I picked up a lot of
buildings in Paterson uh people that
passed away the the kids the grandkids
didn't want to deal with it anymore wow
yeah
what are some of the tax things that
you've learned man because I think some
people don't understand like if because
if you sell a house like let's say you
buy and you sell a flip right yep
um wouldn't it be in your best interest
to take all that money and put it into
another property as soon as possible or
what like kind of give me some of those
tax loopholes that are legal that are
legit that you know well you know
everything when it comes to flip
properties everything is a write-off
right from the interest that you paid
you know your hard money lender the
points everything's a write-off and
everything that you buy your you know uh
the taxes you paid on the property the
insurance everything yeah right off
right so you don't really pay that much
taxes when it comes to real estate
because you have so many riders and so
many expenses that they you could take
off the you have to pay capital gains
taxes on the profit yeah okay if you
hold it for more than a year right uh
you pay less right uh but yeah you have
to pay Capital Gains but again it's all
numbers you know cost of doing business
yeah is the cost of doing business but
there's so many expenses right that you
can write off that uh you know you could
always win you could always to win
rental properties that's really where
you want to be because with rental
properties you have depreciation right a
rental property for some reason right is
considered a depreciating asset so every
year you get to write off a certain
number right so let's say for example
right let's use big numbers
um
I made three million dollars in rental
income last year right but I have two
million dollars in depreciation right so
I could depreciate the asset for 25
years right
so three million dollars I made but I
have the appreciation of two million
right so now I only pay taxes on 1
million
um but I made three million
but then the code because of
depreciation that I can write off two
million so now I made three million but
you're only paying taxes on a million
yep I party with the with the three
million you do yeah yeah but now I only
pay taxes on the million yeah that's wow
that they consider a rental property a
depreciating asset yeah I mean it's
great for for you right yeah hey guys we
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good folks over at
bluetooth.com that's right listen you
got to go to Bluetooth right now sign up
for uh Bluetooth with the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get your first
month for free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient as Viagra Ana Cialis but in a
chewable form that's right you pop the
blue Chew Chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] Raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like are you
looking and he does the [ __ ]
this is gonna be your dick it's gonna be
like ryu's [ __ ] uppercut you know
what I'm saying God bless whoever's on
the receiving end of that consensually
of course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep in discreet packaging
no awkward doctor's visits all right
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in a waiting
room and be like hey Doc uh my dick I
could use a little a pep in my step and
then it's awkward you gotta look at this
old [ __ ] talking about your dick he
might ask you to pull it out who [ __ ]
knows what's going on at Bluetooth none
of that's happening bootchu.com and they
also got the new brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it is that just because it's something
that you're not personally living in and
people like live yeah
stuff like that wow yeah so so you know
that's one of like the best loopholes
are when you're a landlord right yeah
and the cool thing is about it that even
when you write off right that two
million right as a loss
when you go to the bank to apply for a
new loan since they already know what it
is they actually add back that 2 million
so you still qualify for more so ah so
the bank knows you'll still make three
the bank knows what's up yep wow that is
wild man
um talk about you and Envy's
relationship obviously man you guys have
uh
like I said earlier you guys have built
up something really incredible
um how did you guys initially link up
and was it like I mean he's always been
an entrepreneur right like um he's
always been on top of his [ __ ] but like
um your guys's relationship how did that
start what was that so I met MB right
I've been to real estate before I met
him I've been in real estate give and
take
back then about 12 years right yeah
um
and I met him through one of my good
friends which is knit the grit and uh
Danny zoo litigrant and Danny Zoo uh
they own the label where uh fetty WAP
was signed to okay yeah 1738 yeah 1738.
so that that makes sense Patterson yeah
and you know we're all from Patterson
right and I helped them with a lot of
their Investments too early on and
that's how uh they introduced me to to
do you have me yeah yeah and then says
that
um he told me yo you got a pretty dope
story
it was never in my cars to be a public
speaker right I was never thinking about
that uh we announced on Instagram right
no marketing nothing just videos with
iPhone we're having a real estate
seminar 500 people showed up
he threw me in from this no you know
it's funny that MV didn't give me no
pointers didn't tell me anything just
gave me the mic and told me go ahead
figure it out figure it out bro I went
out there man my throat got dry I could
have talked for like the first two
minutes I was looking at my wife I was
like I hope she brings me some water
yeah right and um since that man we had
180 000 people come to our real estate
seminars wow uh about 200 million
dollars worth of wealth was built in our
communities wow for people that invested
in real estate in our through the
seminars wow so like for people who
because you know I think that some of
these
sometimes when you think of like
seminars in general right there is some
stigma that comes with those because
there's people who do like seminars but
it it feels like an extremely
um I wouldn't say a scam right but like
there's there's like a lot of these
self-help guys who will have a seminar
and like I'm not sure what you're taking
from it except for coming out of it like
super inspired when you guys do a
seminar you guys are literally teaching
yep black and white very applicable
things yeah so we break everything down
right we start with credit right because
credit is very important yeah right
especially you know we teach you about
your personal credit we teach you about
business credit we start with that from
there uh we have a a mortgage person
right it's how you have how to qualify
what do you need then we'll have a real
estate attorney we'll have a real estate
broker in that area right that knows
that market we'll have our friends from
auction.com they're talking about their
inventory we'll have a hard money lender
and explain to people how that process
is wow we'll have a contractor there and
then at the end we tell our stories at
our seminars there is no upsell
so you pay anywhere between 100 to 300 a
ticket and that's it that's it there's
no like hey yeah I'm not trying to sell
you a course right I'm not telling you
hey if you really wanted me flipping in
J and DJ Envy during the next seminar
right there in the next seminar with us
tonight you know yeah because that's the
thing too man I've been to a couple of
seminars where you go and they announced
these people they're gonna be there and
they're not there listen I have a friend
of mine who is absolutely obsessed with
Grant Cardone and he has spent
ridiculous amounts of money to hang out
with him at these like I'm talking about
like
stupid money like to just hang out with
Grant Cardone I'm like wait he's like
you know taking selfies with them
they're eating dinner and I'm like bro
how much did that cost like it's wild
when I see [ __ ] like that I'm just like
hmm when you think about it man right
now you know to be honest with your
grand card don't it's kind of like what
Trump was right at one point Trump was
kind of like the face of real estate in
the US right right yeah Grant's
definitely that face yeah he's
definitely that face right now yeah he
got it and he's running I mean he's
turning it up God bless him man but yeah
I think like uh you know I just think
that's dope man for you like uh the
seminar thing obviously
when did you guys feel like you kind of
mastered that because like you said it
didn't start off like you started off
with 500 people yeah like when did you
guys realize like oh right like the
first year in right and then we were
even gonna go harder the next year but
then Colby hit yeah we started doing
webinars and stuff like that but now
it's a little weird right uh we're not
doing as many seminars as we used to
because it's over saturated everybody
now right in the age of social media is
like let's say they sell one house
they're an expert they do one stock
trade they're an expert right they have
one truck they're expert everybody wants
to sell a course everybody wants to do a
seminar so people have to be very
careful because a lot a lot of times you
go to these events into these uh places
and they don't really know what they're
talking about so it's cool right that me
and MV made it cool where people that
look like us to do you know seminars
could be involved in that kind of the
business you know could promote things
like that which is awesome but then we
also made it too easy right well now
anybody thinks they could do it right
and even though they're not really doing
it it looks like you know because the
age of social media you don't know who's
doing what yeah right
um for people who
let's talk about credit obviously
personal credit is important business
credit's a whole other thing uh what
would you say is somebody's easiest
course to correct their credit score
let's say that they're hanging around
like a 600 a 580 and they're trying to
get in that 700 range what are some of
the tips that you could give somebody
like that the the easiest thing right
let's say uh your wife has a credit card
right
let's say you wait for example right on
both
um
if she had that credit card for at least
two years right make you an authorized
user when she makes you an authorized
user you get her good credit history for
the last two years wow so and she
doesn't have to give you the card so it
could be a friend it could be a family
member it could be anybody they add you
as an authorized user but you want to
make sure that as a person doesn't
really use that credit card right right
and now by doing that you could go from
a 600 credit score all the way to 100 a
700. wow 720 within 30 days wow once
it's reported so that's like one of the
easiest tricks that you can do to build
your credit score if you if you know
somebody it's almost worth you paying
them to become an authorized user if you
got oh that's the issue a lot of people
do charge for that for trade lines
that's illegal and now you got to be
careful because I have no pic I know
people in the past that actually paid
people and then next you know they don't
pay the balance on the credit card now
you get a late on you and now your
credit's [ __ ] yeah so you really want
to go to like a personal friend family
member yeah to help you someone you
trust yeah like I got one credit card I
got like 20 people I don't even use it I
just help out you know my friends that
got a little credit scores yeah I would
say someone is saying that um it's my
son's 17 someone's saying I can put him
on a credit card but I don't know if he
has to be 18 or not no so my daughter's
been on my credit card now since she was
like 14 15. and so when she turned how
old is your daughter uh she's about uh
she's 17 she's gonna be 18. so when she
turns 18 will her credit score already
just being a good job good credit wow
yeah she has good credit now oh yeah I
got it I got to figure it out the only
thing is it's certain credit card
companies like I did it with a Visa and
a MasterCard I tried to put her on my
AmEx and they said no right yeah she
wasn't 18. yeah they looked at the
actual date they were like no no yeah
that makes sense
um what about business credit because
I'm like uh right now I have a few llc's
and
um my friend just connected me with a
accountant to try to kind of turn one of
my llc's into an S corp
um when it comes to business credit
business credit is one of those things
that a lot of people don't talk about
right and it's very important and it's a
it's something you can leverage
extremely uh high if you know what
you're doing yeah right so let's say you
have a 720 credit score I got a 720
quarter score
um I get my tax ID right I go on the IRS
website I get a tax ID I create my LLC
right separate entity for myself I go
open up a bank account uh you know
whatever it is Radio Investments right
right well all right that's separate
from me now I go to Chase Inc I go to
MasterCard I go to American Express who
American Express right and now I apply
with my new uh entity for a business
credit card right yeah so they'll do a
soft inquiry on my personal right
because you're behind the loc yeah as
long as I have a 725 score and they'll
prove me right but it will never show on
my personal credit
so now it doesn't affect my debt to
income ratio so now on this side I might
have a couple hundred thousand dollars
in credit credit cards yeah but it
doesn't show here right so it keeps it
separate from my personal name but now
by me doing this with some credit cards
I could take the money cash it out
and invest in real estate or a new
business by leveraging my credit wow so
if you have a 720 personal credit score
at least yeah yeah you got to have that
you you start at LLC you start an S corp
you'll be able to get qualified for
credit cards through your business that
don't necessarily touch your personal
credit yep it's always separate even
cars you you could buy cars under your
business name
right and like that's the another thing
as a write-off like there are certain
types of cars that you could like if
it's a certain weight of a car I think
if it's like I forget what the what the
weight is well pretty much any car you
know like like all you know even our
cars are expensive cars like we have it
under the LC and we write them all off
because technically we drive around you
know so how do you do that property give
me that give me that game man because
that's something that like I was talking
to uh because like last year did I
[ __ ] wrote a fat check to the IRS and
this was I didn't have an accountant I
wasn't really like
this year I'm gonna have an account and
like I said where I'm trying to move so
many stuff that's happening in my
personal accounts over to my business
accounts and the lady I'm talking to is
like yo if you have if it looks like
you're gonna have to like write a 60 or
70 000 check this year like you could
just go buy a car with that instead of
giving it to the IRS so let's say for
example right I have
I go out there and I buy a Bentley right
I'm paying two thousand dollars a month
it's not my personal name right I can't
write that off right it's in your
personal name you can't write down right
now let's see a same scenario but I put
it under the business right so now let's
say I'm paying two thousand dollars a
month uh you know twenty four thousand
dollars a year right give or take I'm a
realtor when I go show properties to
people
I drive my bunny so now my insurance my
payment my uh whatever I spend on gas is
all right off all of it well it's all a
write-off so think about it this way
right uh is a percentage moment because
I heard I heard like certain cards you
only write off a percentage right but uh
but you could all but can't you write
off the depreciation all up front yeah
you could do there's a whole bunch of
things once it's in your business name
right that you could do but Sim very
simple right
a hundred thousand I mean a hundred
thousand dollars a year right I gotta
pay let's say thirty thousand dollars
back to the to the IRS taxes right in
taxes right thirty thousand dollars
I have a Bentley that I use for my
business right I paid twenty four
thousand dollars so a year let's say I
could write off twenty dollar twenty
thousands of write-off so I'm driving 20
out of the 24. yeah so I'm driving my
dream car
right and now I'm saving money on my
taxes because instead of paying 30 you
got to pay 10. yep
and this is my as long as it's under my
company what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
good friends at my bookie that's right
man my bookie is where you want to get
this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview see to
me this is the [ __ ] that people like
these are like the life hacks yeah where
it's like like said like like uh that's
that's that's what I'm trying to figure
out man like I feel like the last few
years I've made so much money I've made
the most money I've ever made in my life
and I'm like
trying to kind of figure out like the
rich guy [ __ ]
the tax game all that [ __ ] man there's
so many loopholes there's so many things
that like you have to because the more
you make the more they want and then
because you'd rather drive your dream
car than write give that money to Uncle
Sam yeah because [ __ ] them yeah you know
like you're throwing money away it makes
no sense right and then eventually the
worst part is as you get older then you
got to do estate planning because when
you die even though you pay taxes on the
money that you already made while you
were alive you got to pay your your
family house they're gonna have to pay
taxes on your money yeah you're gonna
stay too yeah yeah it could be a crazy
sum depending on the state is that a
national thing or does it depend on the
state is different right yeah it's more
the conservative states are like a
little more chill on this state tax [ __ ]
right but you but you know it was like
who was it uh
this guy didn't think he was gonna die
right I wish nobody fought um Tony
Soprano right from uh James Scott James
yeah he did he didn't plan
um he kind of died unexpectedly yeah he
died unexpectedly and he didn't plan for
that and his wealth uh I was reading
that the family lost a lot of it because
it was a plan because he went to taxes
yeah
by the way kind of a jersey Legend I'm
not sure if he's from Jersey but Tony
Soprano was from Jersey bro that's like
one of the best TV shows ever of all
time all the time of all time are you
guys going to have any celebrity guests
on your show oh yeah definitely yeah
yeah like I've worked with a lot of
people you know I worked with a
uh Donald March I just saw Donald Mars
dropping a Daddy Yankee diss I don't
even know if I want to exist in a world
in which they're beefing yeah
Don Omar they can jam uh Snoop I saw you
with Snoop yeah he's the best so so
those are just some of the guys you've
just kind of like yeah give some
mentorship too yeah Nikki James from
Boston right yeah he's a major from
Boston yeah yeah now you know he's the
king of Miami
that's a good place to be a king of yeah
yeah probably it's like he he's one of
the first people that uh we live the
temporary so we go back and forth and
like what he told me makes perfect sense
it's like vacation weather year-round
are you on vacation the whole year yeah
let me ask you this man because like uh
Market wise right like most people want
to buy their flips their real estate
investments in the sexy markets
obviously it's about the numbers right
so like
um I always hear Angela Yee is like
heavily invested in Detroit uh you were
talking about Chicago obviously
Patterson New Jersey
um for you like
it doesn't matter where
because because I don't hear you saying
you're in Miami or you're in L.A or
yeah so when it comes to that right the
biggest bank for your buck in real
estate is going to be in up and coming
areas right
um I've been a master at investing in
urban areas that eventually change over
time so usually any area that's close to
a major city is not going to be Urban
forever right you know the hood doesn't
stay the hood forever right if you want
to use say it that way and the problem
is that most of the people that grow up
in these areas instead of coming back
investing when they're successful they
leave them right and then eventually
somebody else comes in and they make all
the money so that was kind of like the
premise for me in Envy seminar you know
um the cool thing about our seminar is
that
when we started talking about Paterson
New Jersey right
um the values went up a good deal when I
first started talking about Patterson
was probably 150 then it went where a
good deal was 300 and now the average
sale price is 550 to 600 000. but it
didn't become gentrified most of the
people that started investing look like
us right because you guys are giving
that game man so that you know that that
was one of the great things that
happened for the seminar but definitely
men across the country urban areas is
where you get the biggest bang for your
buck don't get me wrong I do a lot of
flips in Miami again Miami sexy I like
being down there I get the biggest bang
for my buck in Miami but it's hard to
get deals on there right so you have to
do a little bit of both but when it
comes to rental properties definitely
urban areas is where it's at how many
cities do you like if you were to just
look at your portfolio you talked about
Chicago Ohio Jersey how many different
markets are you in right now right now
we're in six different states wow yeah
okay all landlord-friendly spots Orlando
friendly yeah yeah but uh like Miami I
don't uh I'm not a landlord I just do
flips there wow so in Florida it's
mostly flips uh Atlanta a mixture of
flips and rentals uh New Jersey I flip
and of course I'm the king of rentals
over here yeah and uh Midwest is all
rentals what about some markets that
you're just uh
you have your eye on Texas Houston is a
great Market Houston's great yeah shout
out to 55th he's doing a lot of stuff
down there oh yeah I think he's living
there now right he's living there now
um that's one of the spots that he's at
Believe It or Not Houston is it has
something that's pretty cool right that
the rest of the country doesn't have
right so in Houston right let's say you
buy a single family home next right you
buy this one family I buy the one next
to you
I could knock down my house and put up a
10 unit project or let's say townhouses
and there's nothing that you could do
there's no zoning
so there's no zoning law over there and
Houston is the only place in the country
that I found so far that you could do
that wow I didn't know that yeah because
I live in Cali and you have to get zoned
to do to build a [ __ ] a a barbecue
grill outside yeah it's like over it's
like you know it's crazy because it's
like California like I'm like obviously
socially a pretty like liberal dude but
living in California man it's just so
overly everything's just bureaucracy red
tape yeah it's just oh they make it so
hard for you to do anything man like
it's a lot so it makes sense shout out
to Houston yeah that's dope man uh when
is do do we first of all have you got
shot on the episodes yet uh no so far we
did a pilot uh we're starting to shoot
something next month in November okay so
I think you know best case scenario
again you know TV takes a long time like
just to get our deal there was a biddy
War right uh for almost six months a
bunch of networks coming at you yeah a
bunch of networks went on the show and
this was uh something that you guys had
collaborated with 50 with originally and
then yeah it was always with 50. right
yeah that's who you want to be with you
know that stuff you know yeah yeah you
know him have you really close of course
yeah and then you know I met 50 uh he
was performing at what's that that strip
club Star Wars Super Bowl in Miami 11
11. oh 11 11. yeah 11. then he came up
to me like you know I see what you're
doing with unmv uh great place to do it
I'm gonna put you on TV yeah and here we
are yeah you're here yeah it's a
beautiful thing yeah you know he's the
biggest you know when it comes to TV
right now you know he's the guy was like
come on you know he's the guy there is
nobody else there's nobody else you know
we're definitely in a good position
right now
um before you go let's break down I want
to break down a couple of things
for anybody watching this the things
that they should have in place
whether it's a security blanket in the
bank account whether it's your credit
score needs to be this whether it's you
need to make sure this is in place
before you dip your toe into this real
estate [ __ ] credit is one of the most
important things you always want to make
sure right you got good credit right you
interview a couple different lenders
make sure you're pre-approved right so
you go out there and pull the trigger uh
learn as much as you can when it comes
to the lengthy side of the business
because a lot of times you might get pre
be pre-approved by A lender that is not
looking at everything so make sure you
speak to somebody and interview a couple
different people right contractors same
thing always talk to a couple different
guys like never just go off of it where
oh my cousin recommended to this guy I
grew up with this guy you can't do that
real estate right but credit right
get pre-approved have a couple dollars
gotta have about you would say about 680
to 720 to start
yeah well it depends though because FHA
you can go as low as a 580 credit score
okay but it depends on the market too
right because for us we're a
multi-family land so FHA is great in the
tri-state area but let's say you're in
Cali you don't really have a lot of
multi-families of course so that that's
the thing right because when uh let's
say if you want to buy a three family
right and you only make let's say 40 000
a year which is not a lot of money you
could do it because with FHA they're
gonna use the two other units to help
you qualify for for that property so now
it looks on paper that you make more
money by using the rents so they're
going to use about 75 to 80 of each of
those apartments so if it's a thousand
dollars they're going to use 800 800 add
that to your total income that you make
a year now you qualify for more but
that's a good hack but you can only do
that with a multi-family depending on
and you have to live in one of the units
yeah you're supposed to you're supposed
to live in one of them and then they use
this guy so I could say You're supposed
to right but you could always refinance
right so a cool thing just to give the
people a little trick with FHA you could
go up to a four family right so the
trick is you can have up to a four Plex
yeah so you want to start with a four
family because you can only go backwards
you can't go forward so meaning you
could go from a four family refinance go
to a three family refinance go to a two
family refinance and go to one family so
each time you get rid of the FHA but now
you're only putting down three point
five percent so each time you get rid of
the FHA when you refinance you can do
another FHA yep you can do it again and
then once you're done write another hack
once you're done in that area you'll go
to a different state and start over so
each state there it's like a blank slate
on the FHA you can always move nobody
could tell you that you can't move wow
okay and then next thing you know you
know again but start start with four
because in order to use that hack you
can only go backwards yeah but the
problem is it's hard to find four
families they're almost like unicorns so
you'll probably get luckier getting a
three or two gotcha that's dope man hey
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our partners at Odd
Socks our presenting sponsor here at the
bootleg hit podcast listen Christmas
Time's approaching faster than you think
I mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview
um yeah we'll go follow this guy he's
flipping underscore NJ yeah so uh
flipping underscore MJ yeah uh me and
envy also have a new platform now uh
it's called Uh flip to dial what's that
uh so that's a real estate uh membership
platform where uh we have all the
education you can think about when it
comes to real estate right I learned
about Harmony loans you want to learn
about developing flipping uh Airbnb
rental properties you click a button the
answer is there by somebody that is in
that business right I don't do airbnbs I
don't do wholesaling but on this
platform you're gonna find somebody who
does it too much maintenance for you
um it's just that you know
it's slower money right that's the whole
thing it's kind of slow for me compared
to what I can make on the other side
gotcha and then you have the real estate
education then you have the Real Estate
Network meaning you need a contractor in
Chicago you need an architect in Miami
you need a plumber in Ohio you click a
button the answer is there oh wow and
then the third part which is the dopest
part is that
we are going to fractionalize properties
into shares so for as little as a
hundred dollars you could invest in if
you would be an MV oh wow from a rental
property to a flip property so if
somebody has some extra change and they
don't want to do they could just buy and
share whatever you guys are doing yeah
and then people the other cool thing is
too which we haven't really pushed right
about the platform is that we're giving
away a house oh wow yeah so people that
become members of the platform they're
going to have a chance to win a three
family in Paterson New Jersey it's worth
five hundred thousand dollars each
apartment uh brings in two thousand a
month so you can flip it for the five or
you can rent each apartment and of
course whoever wins we're gonna help you
with the management so is this a app
website so it's a website so it's
www.flip flip number two Dow d-a-o flips
it out and then
how much is the monthly membership so
the monthly membership is it varies
right so if you want to do monthly is
100 300 and 360. okay if you want to pay
it up front is 1500 uh three thousand
and five thousand for the year yeah okay
no but it's lifetime or for Lifetime
yeah even though the monthlies once
you're done paying the monthlies you
know to whatever the time frame is
you're done and you guys are vetting
like all the contractors to make sure
everybody is on there is legit yeah yeah
that's dope because that's one of the
hardest things right like you said is
finding a contractor you could trust
finding some people that are like good
people to go through whether it's
lenders whatever so you guys kind of do
all that for we pretty much do all of
that it took us a while to come up with
something right because even our
seminars we never really had the next
step right so now this is the next step
right if you want to learn you can learn
if you want the network you got the
network but let's say at that point I
still don't feel comfortable doing my
own deal now you can invest in a deal
with us for as little as 100 and get a
return you know if it's a rental
property will be monthly if it's a flip
property you'll record it wow now you
could a landlord with us that's dope
yeah so if like someone's got 50 Grand
they could throw up 50. yeah so is there
a Max actually let me ask you that the
max is ten thousand okay so someone's
got ten Grand yeah as of right now
though because eventually we are going
to be doing bigger commercials right
bigger deals but it's anywhere between
you know anywhere from a two family all
the way up to 110 Grand people can
invest into a property with you off of
this website and let's say there's 100
properties you could put a thousand
dollars on each property oh wow yeah so
there really is no no Max to it because
when you think about it right when you
think about any other educational
platform right
yeah you get the education but what's
the next step true this actually has
both steps right there yeah so now you
don't got to overthink it there's no
excuse for you to pull the trigger and
that's why we came up with this concept
are you salivating for this Market drop
that's coming
oh a thousand percent yeah of a shark
yeah of course I want I want the market
to drop but but people gotta understand
is it's not gonna be like oh wait you
know that market no but it'll be a
correction right it'll be correct
correction you're going to see more
deals I was uh at the sheriff sale the
other day and I was talking to some of
the asset managers from some of the
banks and they tell me they don't see
foreclosures really hitting the market
hard to like 2025. wow so you still have
a while before you see all that
inventory that's what I've heard I've
heard like even just the correction on
the like the housing cost catching up to
the rate is going to be at least a year
from now yeah because you because this
is the issue right
it supplied the man like anything in the
in the world is supplying the man right
so there is no Supply in the housing
market right now so now you have these
people that that rates like you you guys
did right two and a half to three and a
half percent you're not gonna sell your
house right why would I because you're
gonna yeah you're gonna pay the same
thing you paid except for you're gonna
have less of a house you're gonna have
less of a house and now your rate is
high so now you have that that influx of
inventory does not no one's selling
those houses yes so now you have those
people that aren't selling yeah right
foreclosures are still frozen because of
Kobe right yeah they still have their
forbearance thing yeah four barrels all
that who the hell knows when they're
gonna fix that right now your only other
option is pay rent for a high-ass
apartment
which is what everyone's doing and
you're throwing money away so people
still have to buy houses yeah so we have
a big problem in this country where
there's a housing shortage yeah in
apartments and houses so I don't know
what's going to happen there someone's
got to give yeah something has to give
but even with the rates now it still
hasn't really affected how they thought
it would affect the market whenever you
look at any article now right you got to
read between the lines it'll tell you
there's less sales right you'll see that
in the article there's a housing
recession Less sales but then when you
read the same article tells you but
values aren't going down you know know
for sure yeah now I've noticed I'm like
yo like I mean obviously it's cooled out
like but it's it's not because dude six
months ago like you probably know yeah
there was everything was getting overbid
like crazy people were overpaying wild
amounts of money for these properties
but that's chilled out a bit at least
from what I've seen but like you said
like the overall property value still
isn't really
yeah it hasn't hit like that man let's
see what happens right because it is an
election year so hopefully they're gonna
Something's Gonna Come up right I'm
gonna say when when like we always hear
like uh I've always heard people say yo
it doesn't matter who's the president
I'm gonna get my money yeah did you
notice like a big difference
from when a guy like Donald Trump who's
obviously a real estate guy is in office
and probably is writing codes to benefit
his business to a guy like Joe Biden or
when Obama was in I'm gonna be honest
with you the best years in my business
where the Obama years right Obama came
in he fixed the housing market right he
was great for Real Estate Trump came in
lower rates great for Real Estate Joe
Biden now is not really affecting me
personally right because the thing with
me is I'm also a landlord so it says
reps are so high I'm good right on the
flip side I'm still doing flips I'm
still getting my numbers but it might
change but for a lot of other people he
has affected their business right you
know just let's just talk about last
year right from last year to now uh gas
prices right it's insane all these guys
that I know were investing into trucks
right they're making money in the truck
business making money on tour roads are
taking a loss now yeah because the gas
prices right now you've got interest
rates from up most companies now most
lenders they got rid of almost half of
their Workforce because there's no
refi's so now you know all these images
no one's doing refinancing right now why
it's crazy so there's not that many
people there and they're not going to do
they're not going to refinance for the
foreseeable future because it makes no
sense unless unless you're a guy that
has a hard money loan if you get a 2.7
interest rate yeah how many years you're
gonna have to wait before it makes sense
for you to refinance that yeah that's
what I tell people all the time like I I
got people all the time hey my value's
up I want to cash out refi I tell them
no the Dual cash out refi keep your
original rate and get a lot of credit ah
so now when you need the money you is a
higher rate but and you can get this so
you can also get the line of credit
right and it just is sitting there yeah
so unique and and and it doesn't affect
anything until you touch it right so you
pull the trigger so for people who don't
know like a line of credit is let's say
you bought a house two years ago you got
three hundred thousand dollars in equity
in it at any given time you can get pull
out that line of credit that is not the
same as refinancing yep so let's say for
example you bought a house for 300 000
right now it's worth 500 000. you have
your first mortgage right of let's say a
two and a half percent you don't want to
touch that now your house is valued 500
000. so you could take out ninety
percent of that value minus whatever
your loan balance is right so whatever
that but that's what a local lender
right you want to go to a credit union
or a smaller Bank in your area for the
lines of credit because you get uh you
get uh the LTB will be higher if you go
to a uh let's say a Chase or Bank of
America they'll probably do 80 loan to
value right one of those smaller places
they'll probably do 90 and that's also
another option for somebody who might
want to flip a house or get a rental
property yeah or if you take off that
cash and Equity you leave your original
load balance with the lower rate you
don't touch that you have a new payment
for the LLC yep and then you can take
that money and invest do whatever you
want think about it right if you Equity
is Monopoly money right that's how you
got to think about it if the values go
up or down which is going to happen now
of course that money is not there no
more so you're better off let's say you
take that money out take out a hundred
thousand and now you make three thousand
four thousand from a rental property and
that's going to pay that mortgage for
the amount of credit and your cash flow
would you suggest anybody who has Equity
like that
get that process like somebody who's got
an investor State of Mind somebody who's
always looking would you suggest that
they have that ready at all times just
in case right now like I would do it
like right now like I won't even because
it doesn't affect you unless you spend
the money right it's an effective yeah
you only pay interest once you start
using the dollars so it's just sitting
there in case you want it yep and they
could usually I think you could probably
do about 10 years of just having the
money I'm just sitting in it and then
after 10 years it just expires yep wow
so if you're sitting there and you got a
house yep
because you never know you might come
into a business where like someone's
trying to sell their laundry mat or the
next couple years is going to be very
interesting right until we get a new
president there's going to be a lot of
opportunity right so you'd rather be
ready with a couple dollars to not have
any dollars yeah because like you said
man with some of these situations timing
is everything yeah that's it and if
you're on auction.com you find a house
yeah and you're ready to go yeah you're
ready to go yeah there it is would you
last thing would you suggest somebody
doing that or a hard money loan the LLC
or the hard money line if it's the rehab
right if it's a rehab property I will
always go with hard money okay just
because it's easier to qualify you can
move quick you could play with the
numbers meaning there's a lot of
techniques you could use where you can
actually get some money back at the end
right and kind of cover your down
payment and stuff like that okay when
you go with traditional financing it
takes longer
um but if it's a rental property that
you just want to get a cash flow
property and you need to move quickly
because you already have your primary
residence you go with asset based loan
that's pretty much the line of credit
right no uh asset-based loan is the
stated program
yeah yeah a lot of credit HELOC same
thing got you yeah if you got Equity
sitting there you do a lot of credit or
HELOC and you get that money in two to
three weeks wow there it is man
appreciate your time I appreciate the
game thanks for having me go to the
website sign up for the classes uh
obviously that Flip Flip to dow.com yep
Philippine underscore MJ and then
there's going to be more seminars coming
across the country seminars coming up
you guys got to get on that West Coast
man no definitely man we're probably
gonna be out there I think in April
there it is man appreciate you pulling
up definitely my thanks for having me
boom